j'adore le vélo je me déplace à vélo je
vais au travail à vélo je fais
l'épicerie à vélo et depuis à peu près
cinq ans je fais du vélo de 12 mois par
année
j'ai l'air un petit peu wild quand il
fait moins 20 dans une tempête de neige
mais moi ce que je trouve rire dit si
les gens qu'ils ne disent qu'ils se
déplacent en ville en voiture sûre c'est
vraiment bizarre mais c'est vrai qu'à
montréal le vélo annan et c'est un peu
une curiosité mais dans beaucoup de
villes du monde
le vélo est très possible à l'année en
fait
jal un peu plus loin je dirais même que
le vélo ça va devenir le moyen de
transport principal des fils on pense à
des villes comme comme londres par
exemple où il ya à peu près dix ans ils
ont être d'une politique pour réduire la
congestion des voitures au centre-ville
dont il ya maintenant une taxe pour
entre centre-ville
la ville de oslo 20 heures entre d'ici
2019 une interdiction complète des
voitures au centre-ville
j'étais à barcelone la semaine dernière
et on me faisait l'administration
municipale est en train de préparer un
plan pour interdire aussi complètement
dans toute la vieille ville de barcelone
l'entrée des voitures donc c'est un
processus qui est en cours en ce moment
le monde se déplace vers ce et on va
parvenir à ce monde ancien où la voiture
même complètement la ville mais à mesure
que de plus en plus de gens qui font du
vélo
il ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui
s'inquiètent et pour des questions de
sécurité par exemple à vélo c'est pas
toujours évident de retrouver son chemin
donc souvent ce que les gens font ce
qu'ils vont se promener à vélo avec un
téléphone comme la demoiselle sur la
photo mais aussi beaucoup de gens qui
s'inquiètent de la sécurité
peu de polars sécurité mais c'est de
leur vélo donc
il ya beaucoup d'endroits où les gens me
disent non mais c'est parce que tu
comprends pas le vol de vélo dans ma
ville c'est vraiment quelque chose de
fondamental c'est juste ça le gros
problème dans toutes les villes du monde
est à peu près de deux ans avec un de
mes amis on a commencé à réfléchir à ce
problème
comment pourrais faire pour accélérer un
peu ce mouvement vers une ville qui
puisque liste comment on pourrait faire
pour éliminer un peu les pipelines tout
ce qui rend le vélo en ville un peu
difficile bis qui empêche les gens de
juste prendre le vélo
donc on est arrivé quand le concept donc
je veux présenter le dit mais je
souhaite vous parler de comment on a
fait pour s'y rendre
donc soit et lost est un produit qui
s'installe sur le guidon du vélo et qui
se connectent sans fil par bluetooth à
votre téléphone intelligent et le but
c'est de faciliter votre expérience
christ ce qu'on écrit finalement sur une
interface circulaire qui effets de
lumière de petites lumières des dell qui
permet d'indiquer virage par virage
commenceront à destination donc c'est un
peu comme un gps pour vélo mais vraiment
plus simple donc j'ai pas de carte pas
de chiffres donc juste un cercle se
transforme pour nous indiquer où aller
mais de façon qui peut distrayante pour
l'utilisateur qui permet de regarder les
autres la route dès qu'on arrive à
proximité du vélo la lumière d'en-avant
s'allument automatiquement et des
comptes it
la lumière s'éteint fait son produit qui
reste sur le vélo en tout temps n'a pas
besoin de l'enlever et il ya des
censeurs intégré et si quelqu'un tente
de voler le vélo de façon permanente ça
bouge de façon persistante ça bouge ça
déclenche une alarme sur le produit
enfin c'est possible de suivre toutes
les métriques cycle et donc la distance
la vitesse moyenne qui à l'heure et
brûlé tout ça automatiquement et enfin
ce maté leveaux si nous avertir des
alertes en 30 par exemple un appel sms
ou une tempête de neige s'apprête à
tomber dans les prochaines minutes
en fait cette idée qu'ont eu à peu près
deux ans et séraphine est un peu près
jusqu'à maintenant mais l'idée une
beaucoup changé et
on n'avait pas beaucoup de moyens à
l'époque on s'est dit ah ben oui on a
une idée première étape pour nous l'idée
deuxième étape il se passe quelque chose
que je n'ai pas encore c'est quoi et 3e
étape 1 et 11 mai riches ça de l'art
c'est plutôt que ça mais notre vision
l'entrepreneuriat à l'époque il ya deux
ans ressemblait à cet épisode de ce bug
dont je vous montre un extrait et je
m'excuse d'avancé pour le langage elles
ont calé donc ok c'est peut-être plus
compliqué que ça qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour passer de l'étape 1
j'ai peut-être une des général à trois
je réussis à commercialiser mon produit
et j'ai qu'on a pas beaucoup de moyens
au début effectivement on a commencé
avec 25 d'heures donc on a brisé la
tirelire pour aller ramasser toutes nos
chaînes m 25 $ ensemble donc on n'avait
pas de riche oncle qui pouvait nous
appuyer on avait évidemment pas de
maison à mettant en garantie encore
moins de voitures mais ce qu'on avait
par contre ses comptes t4 cofondateur
avec des avec des habiletés un peu
différente donc on se complétait donc à
4 quand même bien ça fait là samir blanc
200 dollars avec 100 dollars berne à
puce incorporée et ce qu'on a fait à
l'époque si on a postulé sur nous un
concours le qui s'appelait l'époque le
concours québécois en entrepreneuriat on
a postulé à ce concours là seulement sur
la base de notre idée on n'a pas grand
chose à montrer à l'époque mais on a
quand même réussi à gagner au niveau
local donc on a gagné une bourse de 1000
$ avec le 1000 dollars on offrait un
prototype avec une imprimante 3d
président qui était très laid mais qui
était suffisant pour aller à la
prochaine étape et on a postulé sur une
deuxième bourse de 5000 $ et avec son
s'y rendent un peu plus loin on ne fera
peut-être un petit peu plus beau et là
ça nous a permis d'aller chercher un
petit prêt c'était pas un pré énorme ça
ne permettait pas d'aller au bout de
notre idée mais ça nous faisait avant
simple médaille manquée quand même
une somme assez importante pour pouvoir
commercialiser ou même pour finir le
développement qui était qui était loin
d'être terminée donc je ne sais pas si
vous savez où est ce que je m'en vais je
m'en vais à la prochaine slide ce qu'on
a fait c'est sociaux financement donc
c'est pas quelque chose qui est tout à
fait de nouveau mais c'est quelque chose
qui a changé pas mal dans les dernières
années
au début il y avait beaucoup de projets
citoyens des projets artistiques et dans
les dernières années il ya de plus en
plus de projets technologiques
donc en gros le principe c on présente
un projet au public et on fixe sur un
objectif et il faut atteindre l'objectif
dans la période de temps spécifié soit
ans et 30 à 60 jours et il faut
atteindre l'objectif ça veut dire que si
l'objectivité dîner de rap par exemple
et on atteint 1,9 1999 ont touché
exactement 0 $ il faut atteindre
illégalement dépassé l'objectif donc
nous ce qu'on avait fait à l'époque
c'était de demander 67000 comme objectif
pourquoi 67000 parce que ça faisait à
peu près 50 mille dollars américains et
à l'époque on avait toute la misère du
monde à convaincre des bailleurs de
fonds des banques
ce qu'on allait atteindre ce chiffre
c'était vraiment vraiment difficile
finalement c'est objectif est de 67 non
latins à 15h ça s'est passé tellement
vite
à partir du moment où on appuyer sur
play face et elle passé tellement vite
la première journée on a eu des articles
qui ont été publiés dans la presse dans
les affaires mais rapidement ça c'est
assez déplacé un peu comme un jeu le
monde ne vient pas ça s'est passé
tellement rapidement et on l'a vu
c'était passé aux états unis donc lier
des médias américains que commencer à
reprendre une nouvelle phase des
personnes d'amérique du sud
c'est parti en europe et la mesure qui
des articles sur tb le chief montait sur
le site web sur le site de la campagne
donc lorsqu'on a fait son ami un
projecteur dans le bureau pour voir en
temps réel comment le chiffre monte et
j'ai évidemment jamais travaillé ou
tomate de devancer 30 jours de
l'accompagner à chaque jour où
via un nouvel article est publié bon
continue à faire des ventes et les
ventes à mener plus d'intérêt donc
c'était vraiment une période assez
fantastique donc le finalement voilà la
campagne se termine et 538 milles
dollars
ça ne veut ni sur la carte est aussi ce
qui nous a permis de retourner voir les
mêmes bailleurs de fonds qui nous
avaient dit non au début mais de montrer
regardez là on n'a pas juste une idée on
a une idée pour laquelle il ya un marché
pour laquelle et des gens qui sont prêts
à payer pour un produit qui n'existe pas
encore idéalement on vend du vin depuis
plus d'un an maintenant le produit
existe pas le premier pas commercialisé
c'est vraiment juste
on a un beau site web présente ce
qu'elle produit offert éventuellement
payer maintenant qu' on va vous envoyer
le produit si quelques mois donc c'est
vraiment de vendre du vent à avec un
certain rabais soul est ce qui nous
amène un an plus tard
donc on n'est toujours pas millionnaire
le produit pas sorti non plus ceci dit
la production commence enfin bon coeur
on veut produire ici au québec dans le
sol avec sud 2 me de montréal c'est
assez rare pour un produit électronique
donc on est assez faire d'autre le
produit devait sortir en mille 2015 donc
je pense que les entrepreneurs on est
des optimistes on pense qu'on peut
changer le monde
donc parfois on est un petit peu trop
optimistes et finalement ça finit par
coûter deux fois plus cher et prendre
deux fois plus de temps mais le produit
va commencer à être distribuée à tous
ceux qui nous ont appuyés durant la
campagne en décembre et en janvier et
ensuite à tous ceux aussi qui nous ont
appuyés sur notre site
après la fin de la campagne comment elle
s'est donc en gros le sous financement
pour me pour nous ça nous a mis sur la
carte
ça nous a permis de se donner les moyens
de nos ambitions et
[Musique]
encore une fois ça nous a permis de
valider notre marché et de nous donner
l'argent frais de la voilà merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]